b
裾クレームが飛びたい今日はドクター
ああああああ
さあソフトクリームが食べたい私ソフトクリームが食べたい
もちろんアイスではないとソフトクリームが食べたいのかなぜ中なら戦場にツイート
するソフトクリームの流れあれこそ人類だけの dna だよ
[音楽]
ソフトクリーム食べないんですよ私ソフトクリームが食べたいのなんか自宅で食べたい
我がはなんだ自宅でソフトクリームを食べたいかソフトクリームは貴方お店とかでしか
売ってないので私は作れないわけでつまり
つまりこの a だとソフトクリームすることができないのでどうだで方ソフト系も
瞬時にこのように持ってくるしかない
ただその過程においてとっとくネームが熱によって溶ける可能性がかなり高いというか
ほぼカ月にかけてしまうまた食べられない
家づく前に亡くなってしまうだがハングルでないちょっとクリームを購入していいね
下部まで家庭た時ルナ仕方2時間とってその時間は最小限に抑えた上で帰宅日本と夕食
のソフトクリームスンジ食べることが可能であればソフビの食べることが可能であるも
しれないすなわち
ソフトクリームとは別名ソフトツイストなぜツイストかというと命じられているからで
ありますソフトクリームと本来1本の棒状のソフトをお店の綺麗なお姉さんによって
こうねじることによってツイートしていてできたのがソフトクリームは別名ソフト追走
つまりちょっとツイートここにおいて逆回転を回転させるとこう
らせん状
能仁寺書かれていたソフトクリームは逆回転によってこう解けて一気
僕の曲に入る瞬間だけ一方ませんになってこう何よりも早く回目のではないかという私
じゃない気がするんですよ
俺なにいってだう宿に言いたいなこれ知恵ているものを逆に回すと1本のきれいな線に
なる呼べっていう話ですそれはこの上上で瞬間的にバーンとして編んでくれば取り組み
のソフト国も一瞬でくるんじゃねーかという私の仮説である
ではそスチーム国てこよああっ
溶けちゃった早くこういう時も車釣っちゃうからちょっと道路が上がってた方がいい
この時言ったよソフトクリームほんとさえ変わってるあっはい
ん
お母さんおがー僕はさ本家ますがない
受け
ok やり遂げる速度がヤバイはいはいというわけで打つ5月に持ち込むことができ
ました誰でもと切るところから切るね
入ってるつかんだけど東京系がしっかりしていればございしっかり行っていればはい
よくできました
今日は注ぐそれでいこうと思いますいます次へ
わー
[音楽]
me
yeah
dea
car
me
あっはぁ
やってこんな所積んでくるう
シーンいっ
えっ
はい